DETAINED WNBA PLAYER BRITTNEY
GRINER IS SET TO TESTIFY
TOMORROW IN A MOSCOW COURT.
IT'S BEEN ANOTHER INTENSE WEEK
FOR THE 31-YEAR-OLD OLYMPIAN WHO
HAS PLEADED GUILTY TO BRINGING
CANNABIS OIL INTO RUSSIA.
TODAY'S TRIAL SESSION FEATURED A
DRUG EXPERT BROUGHT IN BY
GRINER'S ATTORNEYS TO PRESENT
THE CASE THAT GRINER USED THE
OIL FOR MEDICAL PURPOSES.
A COMMON PRACTICE AMONG
ATHLETES.
GRINER'S LAWYERS SAY SHE DID NOT
PURPOSEFULLY BRING THE DRUGS TO
RUSSIA AND ACCIDENTALLY PUT THE
OIL IN HER SUITCASE WHEN SHE
PACKED IN A HURRY.
SHE FACES UP TO TEN YEARSANE
RUSSIAN PRISON.
WHILE HER TRIAL HAS CAUGHT THE
WORLD TFS ATTENTION, SHE'S NOT
THE ONLY AMERICAN DETAINED IN
RUSSIA ON CANNABIS CHARGES.
MARK FOGLE HAS BEEN HELD BY A
RUSSIAN COURT FOR THE BETTER
PART OF A YEAR AND WAS SENTENCED
TO 14 YEARS IN PRISON.
HE USED MEDICAL CANNABIS TO
TREAT CHRONIC BACK PAIN.
WE REPORT ON THE LESSER KNOWN
TEACHER'S CASE AS THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA GETS
ICIER BY THE DAY.
>> YOU'RE WATCHING THE LAST
MOMENT OF FREEDOM FOR MARK
FOGLE, AN AMERICAN TEACHER
HEADING BACK TO MOSCOW LAST
AUGUST FOR HIS TENTH YEAR
TEACHING THE CHILDREN OF U.S.
DIPLOMATS.
AIRPORT PERSONNEL GOING THROUGH
HIS BAGS.
JUST MINUTES BEFORE HE WAS
DETAINED FOR CARRYING CANNABIS
INTO THE COUNTRY.
HIS SISTER SAYS NO ONE IN HIS
FAMILY HAS HEARD HIS VOICE
SINCE.
ALL THEY HAVE ARE LETTERS
WRITTEN IN RUSSIAN.
>> HE SAYS WHAT HE WANTS IN
ENGLISH.
SOMEONE TRANSLATES FOR HIM, ONE
OF HIS CELL MATES, AND DEPENDING
ON HOW GOOD THEIR ENGLISH IS IS
HOW ACCURATE A PICTURE WE GET OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
VERY CONVOLUTED, AND IT'S
INCREDIBLY WORRISOME BECAUSE WE
CAN'T REALLY HAVE -- THERE IS NO
HONEST CONVERSATION.
EVERYTHING GOES THROUGH THE
CENSORS.
IT'S -- IT'S HARROWING.
>> FOGLE WAS CONVICTED OF
SMUGGLING DRUGS INTO RUSSIA AND
LAST MONTH SENTENCED TO 14 YEARS
IN PRISON.
IN A HIGH SECURITY PENAL COLONY.
HIS FAMILY AND LAWYERS HAVE SAID
HE WAS CARRYING CANNABIS FOR
MEDICAL REASONS.
TREATING CHRONIC BACK PAIN.
>> HE MADE A TERRIBLE MISTAKE BY
TAKING MEDICAL MARIJUANA INTO
RUSSIA.
BUT 14 YEARS IN A HARD LABOR
CAMP IS ESSENTIALLY A DEATH
SENTENCE FOR HIM.
HE'S 61 YEARS OLD AND HE HAS A
VERY LONG HISTORY OF SPINAL
INJURY.
>> THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF HIS
DETENTION HAVE SOME SIMILARITIES
TO THE ARREST OF WNBA STAR
BRITTNEY GRINER.
BUT GRINER WAS DECLARED
WRONGFULLY DETAINED BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT LESS THAN THREE
MONTHS AFTER HER ARREST.
FOGLE'S FAMILY IS STILL WAITING.
>> HE IS WRONGFULLY DETAINED.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THIS IS AN OUTRAGEOUS,
OUTRAGEOUS SENTENCE.
>> AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF DETENTION, THE
CHARGES, FAIR TRIAL GUARANTEES
DUE PROCESS OR LACK THEREOF,
WE'RE ALWAYS WEIGHING THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS AGAINST THE
CRITERIA TO DETERMINE WHETHER AN
AMERICAN IS WRONGFULLY HELD OR
NOT.
>> WHILE FOGLE WAS CARRYING
ABOUT 20 GRAMS OF CANNABIS, MUCH
MORE THAN GRINER, HIS AMERICAN
LAWYER SAYS THAT HIS SENTENCE
CANNOT BE EXPLAINED WITHOUT
THERE BEING A POLITICAL MOTIVE.
>> THIS IS A PERSON WHO HAS
SERVED THE AMERICAN DIPLOMATIC
COMMUNITY AND SCHOOLS ALL OVER
THE WORLD FOR WELL OVER THE
MAJORITY OF HIS CAREER.
I NEED MY PRESIDENT AND MY FIRST
LADY TO STANDS UP FOR HIM.
HE NEEDS TO COME HOME.
>> NOW, THE IMPORTANCE HERE OF
DEEMING HIM WRONGFULLY DETAINED
WOULD MEAN THAT THAT WOULD THEN
LAUNCH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, TO ENGAGE
IN EFFORTS, NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE RUSSIANS TO GET HIM HOME AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND JAKE, WE SHOULD NOTE THAT
THIS WEEK IS MARK FOGLE'S
BIRTHDAY.
AND SO IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
EMOTIONAL WEEK FOR HIS FAMILY,
AS HE HAS TO CELEBRATE THAT
BIRTHDAY FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A
RUSSIAN PRISON.
JAKE.
>> KYLIE ATWOOD AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FOR US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.